[Music]
well we can leave that in i wonder if a
podcast has ever started that way it's
just a cough i'm sure we see there's
probably a podcast that exists that's
just all about coughs no there are so
many podcasts i know that is true um
cough cast
that's kind of a good idea different
or different involuntary reactions not a
good idea you don't think of fart cast
just i listened to a podcast all about
fun you're getting warmer
so to speak
um is it fart warmer than a cough you
think
probably probably the same temperature
because it comes but i would say a fart
might be probably both 98.6 degrees i
think a farm might be warmer only
because it's been in your body long like
a cough is just like
well it's no there's no way to it still
comes from your body who cares how long
it's been in there that's true oh man i
feel dumb but isn't it funny like of all
the stuff i want to cut so far that's
that that would be top of the list and
not the
involuntary cough at the beginning
anyway why should we just start the show
i think yeah well that's uh downstroke
that's an intro i like that story well
should i just do the quick version of
the what we were going to say sure um
last night i
ate too many chess men that was it all
right here's the show life could be a
dream
you're listening to life is short i am
your slightly coffee host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is my bearded
brother he's not always bearded
christian but he's choking it now you
know you say coffee host and you're
drinking coffee oh weird double coffee
oh that's strange i didn't mean to do
that what's that called what is that
grammatical phenomena called uh an
oopsie oh yeah
from shakespeare's
term i think marlow i think yeah anyway
speaking of chess men that you indulged
in last night i did well i have god you
you are a maniac with those things i
have a real problem and i threw the bag
at christian at one point because i
needed him to keep them away from me i
just i can't stop eating them you're
like you're like a junkie i eat them
like chips you're like a junk food
junkie that's i was eating popcorn
earlier and i was popping them as
quickly as i was popping the chest yeah
you eat chess men like potato chips i
don't know how you do it i don't know
how you're what 150 pounds well i've
been going to the gym
doesn't matter no i know i i have a i
guess i have a fast metabolism but i
know it's going to catch up to me so i
have to like i'm worried when i have
those those where i just pull the rip
cord you might just wake up one day and
be fast
you know you might be one of those like
everything just like falls apart um why
are we talking about well my favorite
pepperidge farm yeah you didn't ask me
no i was about to i'm gonna volunteer it
too is uh mint milanos i like mint
milanos a lot they're my favorite type
of they're my favorite flavor milano the
flakiness yeah it i think i think
they're perfect they're satisfying and
there's just enough chocolate to get a
little bit of that and there's it's
the raspberry milanos are good too but
and the orange
mint is the best i saw uh some wild
milano flame flavors recently that it
was like i know there's double fudge
right
and there's also a player on the buffalo
bills called matt milano which always
confuses me and i wonder it sounds like
mitt milano yeah i wonder if matt
milano's listening i wonder if he i
always wondered this when i watch him
play if how often he or if he ever gets
people calling mint milano there's
another milano you know there sure is
our very special guest today is named
milano the star of iconic tv show who's
the boss
the milano that we're referring to is
alyssa alyssa milano alyssa is uh we've
known her since we were kids not
personally but um of course we grew up
watching who's the boss there's a time
for love and a time for loving living
living the rest is up to you my friend
uh do you know the rest and
interestingly enough you are the one who
sang that theme song for for the show
yeah people might not know that when i
was when i was five also that show took
place in our hometown of fairfield
connecticut and i thought that was so
cool you both have to think in school
that is the fictional setting for who's
the boss was your hometown i i did too i
love that show
yeah grew up watching that show i i you
know i associated how good was she
judith light tony danza it's an amazing
show it's an amazing show you sound a
little too much like joey uh a little
joey lawrence
whoa
uh mona whoa that show you know i
associate it with
being homesick from school because
whenever i was homesick from school i
would watch yes every single time i'd
watch that show so it and it gave me
like uh you know when you're feeling
shitty like you're watching people that
you yeah it's like it gave me brought me
comfort yeah yeah it was a real comfort
show you don't both have to be comforted
by who's the boss when you're homesick
from school and of course she's gone on
to do so many other things you know she
was uncharmed yes that was a show that
i i didn't get into when it was on i
didn't know when it was on but it is on
all the time
like charm just one of the shows that
like any time of the day you can watch
it and now she is uh i would say a
pretty major
activist yeah she's a player she's a
political sphere she's a political
player in in the um yeah in the world of
active a rather polarizing figure
i would say that's fair to say right
she's she's quite polarizing she is
polarizing she is a very um she very uh
opinionated and she speaks her mind she
sure does and she often does on uh what
she does on twitter and instagram and
she but i think she like shows up at
those marches and stuff and really like
talks
walks walks the talk walks the talk
walks the walk this is the first time
i've ever gotten to really sit down and
have a so one let's get to know her
better here we go
the
charming and charmed alissa milano life
could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
hey listen do you miss the seasons do
you miss uh living in ally do you miss
the east coast
i mean
with climate change we're now starting
to get some seasons here we had a
thunderstorm the other day and yeah it
was my kids basically their first
thunder ten and seven and then the dog
the dogs were going nuts and i have
horses on the property and they were all
like freaking out like what is this
and of course all of my friends are
texting me like oh isn't it so
you know just so cozy and romantic and
like in my head i'm going no this is
it's the end of the earth yeah what did
your kids think it's like um
what was it like to for to experience
lightning for the first time through
their eyes that's so wild they're like
oh that's lightning right because as a
child the imagery of a light lightning
bolt is you know obviously part of their
world yeah with the chargers now they're
in la they're probably right the
chargers we have we have tickets so for
them to to see like oh that's what all
the fuss is about is that yeah it was
it's really interesting did they think
it was cool were they into it yeah for
sure does it ever strike you like how
different their
lives are from the one that you had like
from from your own upbringing well yeah
for
numerous reasons yeah yeah
you know i joke about all the time that
i have peter pan syndrome because i i
didn't have normal childhood so
i am definitely living vicariously
through
um them we just went toward a middle
school because it's i i don't know how
it's that time
um but it's that time for milo you know
he's in fourth grade which i can't i
don't even understand but i'm literally
walking around this middle school just
like
almost feeling a tinge of jealousy that
these kids are having such
nor even with the masks and everything
it still feels more normal than what my
experience is like because how old were
you alison when you started
i was my daughter's age i was seven
years old when i did the play annie was
it your doing were you like i love it
was it just simple as that for my sixth
birthday my aunt got me tickets to go
see the play annie and i looked at her
and my parents after that and i said i
could do that
and
a year later i was in the second
national touring company
oh
my god do you remember that moment i
mean do you remember seeing it and
thinking that i remember things like
vague
instances i remember
seeing kids singing and dancing on stage
and you know i was such a an artistic
kid that that just made sense to me
you know once i started working i
remember like this feeling that i got
from applause you know and and that it
was definitely lighting up some sort of
reward center yeah reward center in my
brain it's that guy you got a thousand
likes at the same time so yeah and then
i got off the road and did some
off-broadway theater and then went for
an audition for a show a pilot called
you're the boss
you're the boss it was called you're the
yeah originally it was called you're the
boss and then i got who's the boss when
i was 10
oh the first
first season when i was 11 and we went
until i was 19. well and weirdly i it
was it took place in fairfield
connecticut right that's right that's
where i am right now are you in
angela bauer's house kind of
hey mona um
i know i wish i although i remember
talking to tony danza about tony danza
was um
when i met him and i have such a bad
memory that i'm kind of forgetting the
circumstances but i remember my
grandmother and my mother were with me
and i i don't think i had ever seen them
both at the same time so charmed they
were so
charmed by him i am he's a very charming
guy you know they don't make him like
that anymore he's right
he holds people's attention and is very
comfortable in that i feel like
you know actors now sort of
you know are not comfortable being the
center of attention
um or at least they like they feign like
they're not yeah we're like conditioned
to feel like we need to blend into the
walls um but he is very much a showman
um and he does a one-man show and it's
like a cabaret show and he sings and he
dances and were you aware of who he was
and like were you aware of what was your
relationship
like with fame or any kind of
and what and was he famous enough at the
time for you to even consider that in
your 10 year old brain yeah i think so i
mean i knew him as like the cute guy
from taxi
right like that's because taxi was huge
and catherine was on soap
and that was a huge show
so yeah i was aware of of that kind of
that kind of fame
um did it intimidate you i mean were you
like you you always struck me just
watching you growing up you always
struck me as having
a real sense of like confidence and
self-assuredness yeah i think that i i
was always um very comfortable in in who
i was
yeah and really ground grounded which
makes my
adult
not groundedness
a little bit more ironic but yes i there
was that's true yeah there was something
very maybe even stoic about me as a
child i wasn't going to allow many
people in i was an only child too until
i was uh my brother and i are 10 years
apart so that might that may have had
something to do with that yeah
my mother as well she said my uncle the
two of them are 10 years apart and and
she always described it as being a a
little bit less of a sister more of like
a like an aunt to him you know a little
bit more of uh
she had enough authority and she never
felt threatened
by the attention he was getting he was
like my baby yeah i mean that's that's
how i i looked at it and then when we
were
i don't know when he was about 15 and we
started
you know reading the same books and
listening to the same music that gap
began to to shrink and keep that's so
nice he just uh had a baby a couple
years ago and i can't even i am so
obsessed with my nephew
in a way that i just didn't expect i
mean i expected to love my nephew i love
yeah children in a way that you weren't
with your own children you can say it
yeah well that's true it's totally
different with my kids i hope milo's
listening to this one year uh poor milo
so then it became like when you're the
boss became who's the boss and who's the
boss became
this crazy thing
how drastically and how quickly did that
change your life well it felt really
slow because the first year of the show
we were on against family ties
and of course this was back in the day
when we only had three networks yes
and so
we came in
almost dead last in the nielsen ratings
every single week but abc believed
believed in us so much that they just
kept shifting shifting our time slot and
our night
and which would never happen now and
then we ended up
after this is how long ago this was
after happy days in the final happy days
oh
my god i always forget happy days bled
into that
80s
like mid 80s that's crazy and then we
were a top 10 show for the
you know remainder of the seven years we
were on the air out oh my god yeah we
had a we had a rough a rough start but i
would say
it started getting
weird
for me just because i was not used to
not being able to go any place without
being recognized yeah when i was about i
would say
maybe about 13
wow
and that was kind of my existence what
were the beginnings like what did it
feel like in the beginning with the
first few inklings that that might now
be your existence was it was it you
probably had no way of knowing that it
would be sustained but
was it cool in the beginning was there
an element of like oh cool
no i was the kind of kid that always
wanted to try to figure things out and i
could never figure out like why
right i was chosen to live this this
existence
it wasn't uncomfortable for me but it
was uncomfortable for my family
and i knew that them being uncomfortable
and feeling so protective of me in
public
made me
worry about them i bet
so
so where you know i think kids worry
about their parents all the time that
was my worry was like oh i'm causing
this there must be there must have been
a degree of shame
yeah exactly it was it wasn't shame it
was just like responsibility why me and
a responsibility and and a little bit of
embarrassment so it wasn't yeah
it wasn't shame it was embarrassment of
things like you know going through
puberty in front of all of america you
know and having people like dissect you
and when i started developing they would
they wrote it into the show i mean i got
a script on a friday night after a
taping called sam's first bra and i was
like um
you know i was
i was probably 11 or 12 at the time
i was mortified
i bet because you probably even hadn't
even had those conversations with i mean
that's such a such a delicate time such
a vulnerable thing to go through
yeah i didn't go to a regular school so
i think
had i gone to a regular school
i think a lot of it would have balanced
out but because i was tutored on the set
for nine months out of the year
you know um there there was no real
balance and so were your parents in any
way
so they it doesn't sound like they
pushed you into it at all it sounds like
it was something you really wanted to do
no end to the point where
my mom didn't even come to set with me
she hired a guardian because my brother
was so much younger
and it was
it was so important to my mom to be also
his mom
and to
you know have dinner on the table and
when i got home from work and
she would tell you you know her job was
to make sure my panties were clean not
to highlight my my lines
and so okay
and so
yeah
so she you know it wasn't it was my life
it wasn't their lives yeah and did you
have friends who were outside that world
outside show business that you were able
to kind of have a more normal
um
you know friendship with not really i
mean my first real friend i was i was 19
and he's still my best friend
oh how nice yeah but most of the time i
i was just around grown-ups
and
guy kids boys must have been weird with
you i mean i can i can imagine they must
it was awful yes it was just really
hilarious
it was yeah it was traumatizing i bet
and how did your parents
protect you from that like what was
their move
how did they shield you from that love
just love just love and like a constant
reminder of
you know the things that are important
in life i was other things beside an
actor or a child actor i was also a
sister and a daughter and a poet and a
an artist and
a skateboarder whatever it whatever so
that didn't become your identity
exactly people know you now you are
doing something that is kind of
transcends acting and and you're doing
something you're really using your voice
and uh you've become a huge activist
and when did that begin because i i
remember seeing
donahue i remember seeing you and ryan
you kiss ryan white which was an amazing
thing that a lot of people may be
listening to this weren't aware of or
had forgotten about but that to me was
like
because we were similar age i remember
being really struck by
that and
the courage that that took to do that
and and the impact that that had was
that when it began would you say that's
when it began for sure yeah i mean
um
everything made sense
to me after that moment after that
that uh realizing what it meant to be
um in the public eye and all of the good
it could could do
in
complete i mean ryan was a hero he
completely reshaped the narrative of hiv
aids in a time
when
um
it was
it was there was a lot of stigma
attached and our government sort of fed
into our biggest our biggest fears and
and worries
not much has changed in that respect but
but it it was a defining moment in my
life because um
i just felt like talk about your reward
center lighting up
yeah i felt like
this is why i get it now really fed you
i get it i get it now god from that
moment on i didn't i don't know fame
without activism you know interesting
yeah seems like i'm a lot more active
now because
i get to control my platform with social
media
but back then i mean you know we had to
we had to wait for someone to want to do
in an interview with us to share
who we were you know
how how did you come to meet ryan white
elton john
which just gives you a a
little glimpse into how
obscure my childhood was
yeah well what kid doesn't know elton
john right but um he so elton uh
you know who
was such an advocate and activist
for the lgbtq plus community then
uh just as he is now and
he uh recognized that that ryan white
his story was different because
he
uh contracted hiv from a blood
transfusion
and he was a kid and he
realized that that
ryan put a human element
uh that was lacking
um that led people to feel a certain
amount of empathy and compassion
um and so
he and ryan became friends and
through that friendship elton learned of
ryan's love for me
and so he introduced me to ryan oh wow
and ryan and i became
very good friends and so asking me to
kiss him on the donahue show came from
from a
very
deep love for each other yeah i bet and
and a sense of responsibility that that
you've now really you know used to great
effect that you mentioned your platform
and being able to use that to affect
real change and that was huge i was huge
for
me i mean i was
i was being fed the same stuff that
everybody else was in terms of
the stigma surrounding aids and and um
that went a long way that was huge what
you did the thing that i think was
very different though about that time
was that we were encouraged to use
our fame for good then um and and when
you look at people like
audrey hepburn when you look at people
like danny k
paul newman when you look at roberto
clemente you know like even athletes
jackie robinson there was us you know
the entire civil rights movement were
celebrities standing behind with their
fist in the air and and handing over
their platforms to people so i don't
think i think that people in our
entertainment industry i think i think
we were scared into believing that
half of the nation would not buy our
products or watch our tv shows if we had
an opinion about things and i think that
that may have been a very successful
strategy
by
the republican party because they had
very few celebrity supporters because
you know after the civil rights movement
when the democrats realized that it was
unjust for them to try
to uh keep because originally it was the
democrats
who um you know uh tried to suppress the
black vote
um
and so
yeah
and so once that had uh
had shifted i mean i think
we were really encouraged to to use our
voices and it wasn't until this like
big hollywood machine came in and
you know put the fear of
god into movie stars where you know they
were allowed to have a voice
right like you said it does go bad goes
back to charlie chaplin i mean like
charlie chaplin was literally run out of
america for um
for standing up to to the powers that be
um
is there more of an impetus to do
this kind of work now is there ever a
part of you that wants to redirect your
energy back into acting to to doing some
to to acting again or is it are you more
fulfilled through this work it's real
hard
after you've had this experience and
mind you i i don't just mean political
activism but i'm also an ambassador for
unicef i've traveled the world i've seen
some really really hard hard things to
see and i've always been incredibly uh
boots on the ground
i lived in south africa for three months
in 2000 i've been to angola africa only
two years after the peace treaty was
signed for the longest civil war
in the history of the world
um india six months after the tsunami
i've been all over the middle east
visiting troops i've been
in kosovo
um
so
i only say this because
um
once you've had these experiences
the entertainment industry becomes a
means to fund
right right active is my activism and
advocacy work i bet yeah because i have
a very hard and to also maintain a
certain level of fame because they sort
of feed each other yes i mean well but
like you said it's the stakes are so
much higher so clearly higher to have
done all of those things i can't imagine
how then fickle and superficial it must
seem to go back back to oh yeah you know
what part am i playing now and
right and hit this
tape mark and say words that you didn't
write and yeah and they've somehow
figured out a way to take a lot of the
artistry out of acting i don't know how
they i don't know how they pulled that
off
[Music]
one of my favorite aspects of the
holiday season i love the sounds the
sights of course watching the lights the
christmas trees and but i also love the
smells of the season the chestnuts
roasting and the smell of pine and i
also now love my own smell
after odor brag i owe it all to native
natives new seasonal scents are here and
i
could not be more excited because i am a
loyal native user i've been looking for
a healthy natural deodorant ever since i
heard about how bad aluminum and
parabens and sulfates are for you but um
i was never able to find one that that
actually worked that made me smell
better and and
covered up body odor frankly and now i
have i'm so thankful to them native
they're the best they use natural
ingredients like coconut oil and shea
butter they never use aluminum parabens
or sulfates but like i said it still
keeps you smelling fresh all day i don't
know how they do it but i love the smell
and now i'm excited for these new
seasonal scents
candy cane sugar cookie which i'm afraid
to try because i might try to eat my own
armpits um and fresh mistletoe so keep
the scents of the season with you with
natives limited time holiday scented
deodorants go to native d-o-d-e-o
dot com slash long or use promo code
long at checkout and get 20 off your
first order that's native
deo.com long or use promo code long at
checkout for 20 off your first order i
used to have quite a bit of trouble
sleeping and i know christian did too
he's not here but uh i can i can attest
to this um our sleep has improved and
it's improved thanks to three
very important letters c
b and a d
in this case i'm talking about plus cbd
it's a gummy it's a sleep gummy that's
formulated by a team of medical experts
and doctors they taste great they're
made of award-winning cbd combined with
melatonin magnolia bark lemon balm
um you can sleep better it really works
i mean i've tried a lot of things a lot
over the counter things that leave me
feeling kind of groggy and weird in the
morning i never feel that way i wake up
feeling refreshed ready to go four out
of five people say that they suffer from
poor sleep at least once a week i used
to be one of the four out of five and
now i'm in the minority i'm one of one
of five people who sleep great thanks in
part to the plus cpd gummies we've just
got go to pluscbdoil.com and enter promo
code long for 40 off your order 40
so it's easier to try it so visit
pluscbdoil.com and enter promo code long
for 40 off your order
[Music]
you've had so much experience in network
tv uh
a lot of that has
felt a little bit more forced and less
natural to me
has your experience changed in terms of
how you see
acting uh how you see the scripts that
are coming have you fallen out of love
with it to some degree i don't know that
i was ever in love with it i think that
i was always and i think that that
enabled me to reach a certain level of
success
yes but here's my problem
okay and it if my problem is this
i have fought
really hard to be this woman that i am
right now
and it's through you know a lot of hard
work and therapy and self-exploration
and
reflection and really uncomfortable [ __ ]
it has become harder for me
to walk on a set
and not be me
and to dive into
my
emotional well
to portray someone else right right to
dive into
you know like i just did a movie for
netflix that'll be released in or
dropped whatever they say um in january
and my sister dropped yeah dropping you
you made it dropping yeah my sister uh
dies on page on page four and so
you know for two and a half months i'm
walking into work every day and to
having to tap into my own emotional well
um that i've worked really hard to heal
oh i see yeah huh and so now it's like
it's like um
yeah you're just
scratching a scab constantly
and that's what we we do as actors right
we yeah we we go back to our own trauma
to to be able to
you know
project emotion it has become harder and
harder for me to do the more healed
healed i am and some actors do they find
it therapeutic
for me it gives me anxiety
huh oh interesting it's probably in a
weird way making you better you know i
mean because when you do accept
something like that you have to really
like you do with your activism you have
to commit i mean if your sister dies on
page four unless it's a five-page script
which would be
hilarious um
you have to really make maintain that
level of commitment which is
yes but it's kind of like
it's kind of like childbirth where
you it's so excruciating but then
something happens
when you're you know when your kid's
like 18 months old where you kind of
forget about the hard
the the trauma of actually going through
it and you're like you know what i could
do that again i've always wondered that
listen because this similar thing i've
that's happened to people in my life and
i always wonder if that's just like an
evolutionary thing if that must there
must be some evolutionary mechanism
that it's the combination of oh now it's
an age where it's really cute they're
not constantly [ __ ] themselves um
and you you like you said
forget forget about the
struggle
the struggle yeah and that's kind of
like working on a on a
movie or a tv show for me oh okay so i
do know about childbirth yeah so well
no no you said it you said that i know
exactly how childbirth feels um
well have you ever thought about then
get like giving that up then and and
running for office i i wonder this about
you often like because you are
i mean you are so good at what you do
um and it sounds to me like
you just enjoy it more on a very
purely superficial level so do you ever
think about just oh yes i'll run for
office yes it feels like that would be a
natural progression
my
my thought though is i'm not sure i'd
get as much done
all of my friends who are in congress
whether they're in the house of
representatives whether they are in the
senate whether they are state senate or
yeah or you know municipality whatever
whatever it is
yeah all your friends yeah my buddies
ted ted cruz ted cruz
yeah you know all my buds they um joe
manchin they are all very
uh
frustrated
and a lot of them were activists and
community organizers actually the most
effective legislators i know were
activists and community organizers but
you
have to be okay with the incremental
wins
i don't know that you're ever working to
solving issues if you're an elected
official it's just pushing stuff around
it's just seems like it's just moving
stuff like that and it's also it's like
making sure [ __ ] doesn't get rolled back
uh-huh yeah that the fights that were
already won
how do you keep then my my question now
because how do you keep from being too
spread out i've see i see you everywhere
i see you with voting rights i see you
with me too i see
you are active in so many areas of
activism
how do you do that without being
overwhelmed i guess
by all of the injustice i'm always
overwhelmed
okay so i'm not saying i'm not saying
i'm not overwhelmed i am overwhelmed but
i have a hard time saying
no
yeah asked and also i look at it as
a challenge
to be able to educate and empower myself
to learn about all of these different
issues and the history of them and
be creative in my thinking on how to
manage them in a different way or get
people looking at things in a different
light much like what ryan white was able
to do what was he like by the way like
what was he like as a person what are
your
memories of him he was courageous but
like hanging out like when you guys
would like be around each other he was
funny
he was funny he was self-deprecating he
was was he scared was he afraid he never
let on that he was afraid i'm sure he
was because by you know the end he was
very sick
uh and he had to fight to go back to
school and he spoke in front of congress
i mean this the weight of the world it
was spend your last
amount of time with that kind of
scrutiny and pressure really amazing
what he went through there are people
like my friend adi barkin who has als
who is
i mean he is a civil rights attorney who
has
dedicated his last and final days in you
know medicare for all and getting
everyone
health care and he's just you know
they're there are really miraculous
incredible people and if they can keep
going
then i can keep going i mean
i might be a little medicated but
yeah well whatever gets you through the
night
uh are you are your kids ever like
mom relax are they ever like
how do you how do you
filter this stuff because a lot of it is
[ __ ] it's a lot of it is overwhelming
and
deeply sad and how do you filter it
so that they're not absorbing a lot of
that
you know what i don't really
have to filter it because they see it in
such a beautiful pure way
um like for instance uh
when we were fighting for dreamers uh
daca in 2017 2016 or 2017 i told him i
was going on a bus tour and we were you
know i told them all about dreamers and
and how
our president was was trying to send
them back to countries that weren't
their homes and this was the only home
that they knew and in some instances
they didn't even you know know the
language of the countries that they were
being sent back
to and my son after this whole long day
of being on the bus
uh with dreamers i opened i opened the
door and he looked at me and he said
did you win mama do the dreamers get to
stay home and i was like
that's it
that's it yeah if we could just
de-politicize every issue and bring it
down to its most fundamental right well
that's what i love about a group that i
know you're familiar with uh our friend
elsa this is about humanity
um
that's what they do i mean that's at the
at the heart of their work is about it's
about people and that's what's been so
beneficial to me when i get to actually
see the people that are benefiting from
what they're doing and the fundraising
because because some of these things
sometimes it can become like you know
this better than anyone it can just
become this abstract thing it must be
frustrating to you to do work for a
political to
help promote a political candidate uh to
do surrogate work and then
see them maintain this
really inhumane status quo do you have
access to these politicians are you able
to say to them
you know do you have the the direct line
do you have the bat phone where you can
say hey what the [ __ ]
i have
connections with uh president president
biden
um i did i i had a bat phone during the
the campaign i do not have that bat
phone anymore
but um my activism
is critical of both sides of the aisle
and
i don't think just because a democrat is
our president um they should
be void of criticism when criticism is
due and by the way it's the whole
democratic party right now is yeah is uh
disappointing many people um yeah and
and you know part of me feels like
everything that we sent them to do
joe biden had a very progressive uh
platform the most
progressive we had seen
from from a candidate um maybe not a
primary candidate but from a yeah
from a presidential candidate yes um and
he was very smart he borrowed from all
of the most
progressive candidates in the primary
and took ideas from everybody and
listened to organizations and listened
to grassroots organizations and listened
to activists and listened to advocates
and
um
you know we
we kept the house we flipped the
senate-ish
and we sent the president in record
numbers
to dc to fulfill a very progressive
agenda and it has been incredibly
frustrating
for uh
activists
everywhere
to not
now mind you if we can get build back
better
past
it is going to
change the lives of many american people
and at the end of the day i think that's
the most important thing
but there's a lot that i i'm
disappointed in thus far
do you ever um you had mentioned the
dangers of social media and um
how it can be overwhelming do you ever
take breaks do you ever and and if so
how does that affect you i mean how are
you affected by
um staying off social media for a length
of time
fine with it actually there's there's it
it seems like i'm on social media all
the time but i am uh really good at um
like composing tweets or making tick
tocks weeks in advance and then just
dropping something
um you you compartmental you have a time
for it you you yes yeah
yes yes you have to and um you know i i
paint and i am a gardener and do all
sorts and i i love to read and so i do
all sorts of
um things too that that aren't
you know about uh
activism and advocacy work
well my other questions are all about
gardening so perfect
bring it
uh what is your prize what's what's the
thing that you brag most about your like
uh
your garden brag i have uh well i have
80 oak trees on my property at 80
80 yes and
we just um
lost one we had an arbiter come out and
it was it was uh it was whole holed out
in the middle and becoming dangerous so
they cut it they cut it out but they
left this beautiful
uh oak tree stump
um
that i have started gardening in
oh wow yeah it must be so fertile
because they're like rotten
but it looks so beautiful and it's like
it's just yeah it's really cool so
that's that's my little project right
now but i
i make turaniums and do all sorts of
do all sorts of things like nerdy things
i got so into it during the quarantine i
it's all i kind of started doing on
instagram in fact was showing off the uh
my produce that i was growing
japanese eggplants i got really into um
i i feel you it's it's it's actually
when i feel my most relaxed i think me
too it's my happy place
your book uh you have a gardening book
in fact called sorry not sorry it's all
about regarding gardening
um nobody but it contains 32 essays
describing your activism uh thoughts on
current issues why did you name it why
sorry not sorry i think i know but i'm
curious
well the subtitle was going to be
stories of being unapologetically [ __ ]
up uh-huh
why [ __ ] that why would you say if
somebody said okay so i've never heard
of you i let's decide an alien comes
down from the planet never seen who's
the boss
only saw the pilot when he's you're the
boss
and um
and they say well
why why are you [ __ ] up why would you
say you're [ __ ] up that's a lot to
unpack that question there's a lot of
there's a lot of trauma there's a lot of
feelings other
uh-huh you know so i mean you're [ __ ]
up in this but in in this in the context
of the title [ __ ] up refers to
everything all
right everything dysfunction yeah listen
this is who i am these are my opinions
sorry not sorry okay i'm apologizing for
not being sorry
okay okay
are there times where you do feel like
oh [ __ ] i messed up have you ever felt
like oh i may have gotten this wrong and
i do now have to say i'm sorry oh yeah
and i'm sorry but like for sure for sure
but i think
the blessing is is that i get to
[ __ ] up in a really public way
and deal with it with as much grace as
possible
and promise to [ __ ] up less the next
time
and and hopefully that makes the idea of
taking the fear away from people with
holding their empathy
you know if they can say oh look she
said the wrong thing doesn't mean our
hearts in the wrong place and she's
dealing with it with grace and she
apologized
um
and so i feel really blessed that i get
to do that publicly i mean you gotta you
gotta you gotta remove the ego from
the work but i don't think the ego can
be married to
activism anyway well otherwise there's
no room for discourse or for being wrong
or for
seeing things another way also you
you're
attached to an outcome
and with activism
the only thing that you can do is plant
a seed yeah i look at people like alice
paul who wrote the equal rights
amendment which is my tombstone issue
and
she never got to see the
all 38 states ratify
you know the bill that she wrote the
amendment for the constitution that she
wrote
in 1920 but it might pass in my lifetime
so
if we're talking about gardening which
is what my book is all about you have to
be okay with with planting the seed
and allowing someone else to harvest the
fruit what do you do when it becomes too
much do you detach ever from it do you
unplug how do you clear your mind
take a gummy and have a margarita okay i
thought you said i'll take a gun a gun a
gummy a gummy yes a a weed gummy and a
margarita five milligrams what's your
ten milligrams
ten ten milligrams and i'll just uh
paint or
play in the dirt or or whatever that's
the best god bless marijuana do you ever
watch um
do you ever watch like trashy tv or do
you have a guilty tv pleasure i mean i
don't spend a lot of time in front of
the television which is so ironic
yes it is
what do your kids think of your stuff i
mean
i'm sure charmed comes on or who's the
boss i'm sure something you're on comes
on it some hour of the day they have no
desire to that my son is really really
my son really likes looking at my tick
tocks because he thinks i'm really funny
but as far as
as far i tried to get them to watch
who's the boss they were so
they're like okay mama look at you you
look just like bella and that's my
daughter and then they
you know ran off to play soccer or
something
no kidding we have the same chapstick uh
flavor i don't have it on me which i
wish i did cherry chapstick the best
um
that's so funny so they have no real
interest in
funny
and i would and i would actually say
that they're more interested in in my
activism than they are my acting
oh my gosh well also dave your husband i
mean like you must be around a lot of
actors that they recognize are there are
there ever people that they get excited
about like like superhero people
this is a sweet story my my son was
really inspired by amanda gorman's as we
all were a poem at the inauguration
and um
he decided that he was going to write a
poem
and so i sent it to her and she posted
it on her social media she pawned it off
as her own work no
no no i'm kidding
oh my god could you imagine well this is
a scoop no
[Laughter]
no no we're cutting out all the parts
where you
[Laughter]
no she she posted it and said this is uh
my my nine-year-old friend milo wrote
this
and so he he thought he was a big shot
from that
and i just thought that that was really
special um
you know nice thing to be celebrated for
too we call uh yes exactly we call um
bradley cooper in this house his uncle
bradley
um
but they don't
bradley around them because bradley's
he's so good at like making you feel
special and you know man you look so
good i can imagine he's very charming
with the kids he's very sweet with them
and
um he never forgets uh one of their you
know with their birthdays or oh that's
really sweet he sends me and my husband
anniversary gifts every single year
really for our wedding
are you serious yeah well he spoke at
our wedding 13 years ago or whatever and
you know he's been through all of his
friends being
with people and divorced and and
and we are still going so i think he's
just he's really overwhelmed uh by that
i feel that's a rare thing
in our
business yeah it is wow yeah so yeah
uncle bradley um
my son wrote a letter to governor
desantis about um
the
wild cougar crossing that was happening
in uh
in florida the animal yeah
that that um
my son was very upset with and i i
recorded him
reading it and then i sent it to mark
ruffalo
and i was like
so you know you can totally say no to
this but it sure would mean a lot and if
you could give him a little
encouragement
um and so mark sent him a video and
milo was like oh cool i don't know
that's
yeah it's the hulk well maybe he well he
wasn't he hadn't hulked out you don't
want to get one from bruce banner it's
not as fun life could be a dream
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wandery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
we have a lightning round
um if you don't indulge me
okay
here we go
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say your go-to emoji the winky
kiss winky uh
winky and kissing with a little heart
coming in yeah okay uh yes i love that
one if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play you're
wearing a dodgers shirt i need to point
out to everyone yes i would be a
professional baseball player i would be
a catcher
a catcher yeah now why a catcher because
they control the entire game from back
there yeah that's true
you'd have to get hit a lot um
potentially
and also they're involved in every
single play right every every pitch
every single that's true so i mean i
couldn't be an outfielder because i'd be
like looking at the sod
you know see you know what's funny well
this is how different we are this
actually is like a perfect example of
like how i have such fear whereas you
are there's a there's a courageous
that's a courageous answer because i
don't know if i'd be able to deal with
that pressure i in fact i remember
playing baseball and playing both
positions and not dealing with with the
pressure because outfield is like every
once in a while ball comes to you but if
you mess up that's even more pressure
exactly the outfield yes as a catcher
being involved in every single play
keeps your mind in
the game and focus so that it's true you
know one one past ball isn't as
monumental as you know if if you make an
error an error in the outfield and it
you know makes a
stretches a single and into a triple oh
it's humiliating yeah i feel like you
guys go to games a lot we do but we
we're we're a very sporty family you are
who's your football team
uh the new york giants because
david's father is the head of the chain
gang at 85 years old he runs out there
with the yardstick what and measures the
yardage
for the new york giants
mm-hmm
he's still doing it at 85. still doing
it holy god he's still coaching
soccer he just had his 899th
win as a high school soccer coach
in new jersey what he's in the soccer
hall of fame my father-in-law besides
just being
just an incredible
incredible human but he's just oh my god
uh if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life what would it be
cheez-its cheez-its
great oh my god i love cheez-its so much
yeah you didn't that was so quick you
had that
it was so accessible
jesus
yeah they're delicious the good
old-fashioned kind in the in the red box
not the crisps
not the like ranch fake flavor the
cheddar oh yeah i know they're getting
crazy yeah would that mean that you you
also really like goldfish other kind of
like cheesy type snacks like
cheese based snacks no i don't think
anything compares to a cheez-it oh wow
really you're a real purist yeah um
what was your uh what was the movie that
you really we talked about like your
kids watching your stuff and being very
ambivalent about it but was there a
movie that you were excited like when
you had kids like you were really
excited to show them like that was maybe
something that was important to you when
you were a kid
i was really excited to show bella the
wizard of wizard of oz
and
she was really into it my son i'm still
waiting i i want to show milo um
searching for bob bobby fisher and oh
really um the goonies oh i can't wait to
show him yes the goonies i get why
searching for bobby is he into chess
because i think that it is a universal
theme for
children who are over achievers and
parents who
push their children
maybe a little too hard oh interesting
um and i just think i just think he'll
really enjoy it um have you ever done it
that bell is too young for this but have
you ever done the wizard of oz where you
sync it up the dark side of the moon no
but when you're on a gummy i
i know i know i've done it i've done it
oh you have i've done it for me yeah i
haven't done it it's wild right it's
it's wild but here's the thing is
i think everything
has a rhythm to it yeah maybe maybe so
and i think sometimes that rhythm
synchronizes to something else to
another rhythm and when those moments
you know like when you're in the car and
you have the windshield wipers going and
all of a sudden they just
sync up to like the don't walk sign
flash yes totally
or a song that's playing even the
everything is working together so i
think it's in harmony yeah i think
there's a rhythm to everything uh huh
well you must see that too because you
live among nature it sounds like you
live there's a lot of
nature where you live so you must but
also
like writing too you know writing yes
there's a lot of uh rhythm
in being able to compose a sentence
impactfully i think you are
correct sorry i was trying to do one
without rhythm um
what is your what's your go-to karaoke
song you're out singing you're actually
one key nope nope
i don't have to i can't if you're at a
jukebox what beatles song would you like
to hear right now
blackbird ugh yes god who was your first
celebrity crush
um so see thomas howell
um but then there was someone else that
i thought of the other day and i can't
remember who that person was now but
yeah see thomas howell
like in the outsiders
yeah right yeah ponyboy
is it
how
what you must and dave must have this
experience where people say that to you
all the time oh my god you were my crush
as a kid like people at parties must say
that to you all the time
has that gotten any
is that it must just be a part of your
life how do you how do you what does
that do to you how do you feel about
that
i always
am worried that
meeting me in person is somehow a
disappointment from whatever
from whatever the fantasy that they have
right that they have like
you know created of me in their own head
that yeah you know
i i have this this clothing line where
it's all sports licensed and um we do
signings a lot at stadiums and i always
i get these these sports fans that are
like oh my god when i you know you were
my first crush and and whatever and i'm
always like oh my god
and that's when i was like in my prime
at 18 and now i'm almost 50
and this [ __ ] guy is looking at me
this close
oh that's weird and i must be like and
i'll say i hope i'm not disappointing
you
oh man
that's
so strange yeah i know i also started at
a certain point like gauging my own age
when adults
would come up to me and i didn't start
that young
and they'd be like i watched you growing
up and like growing up you have a full
beard
but i didn't realize that i was aging
until like everybody else my age looks
old well you mentioned your peter pan
complex yeah i mean i uh there's also
some botox involved in that but
well that makes it easier to not
recognize aging
yeah i was gonna say you don't look like
you've aged
but i i keep looking at it but it's not
even like how i feel like i look it's
just
a recognition of
being middle-aged by seeing how other
people
are middle-aged if you had to get a
tattoo
oh you have tattoos but if if you do
have tattoos if you got another one what
would you get
uh probably my kids names uh-huh my lone
pillar great names by the way
um
what is your favorite fruit apple a
fujiya an apple who is your favorite
muppet growing up animal of course of
course um he made me laugh he still
makes me laugh did you ever get to do a
thing on sesame street i never got to do
anything on sesame street i would love
to do that uh yeah what is your go-to
pizza topping just cheese
i'm a
real originalist okay uh dogs or cats
dogs do you have dogs i have five dogs
oh wow okay all of them five dogs nine
horses eight chickens two bunnies you
have two bunnies i do
i am
that's good that's cool that's a minute
i rescued two bunnies yeah i i again
like i don't know how you do all of it
but i'm glad you do me too i mean these
are these are the things that make me
feel like a you know a human well good
well you are a very impressive human i'm
so glad i got to do this with you it's
really cool to get to talk to you thank
you i really appreciate your support
thank you so much
[Music]
so so that happened that just happened
uh a very um
very recognizable voice that
was did i know that i was like i took my
foot off the gas and didn't commit so so
that just happened it's time for me to
do you're doing like are you doing a
little s seductive
sounding that sounds a little seductive
yeah well i was thinking could that be
may i posit this theory yeah so that in
your brain
alyssa milano is associated with
your youth yeah and maybe having a crush
on her no so you
there's a part of you that still thinks
of her as yep seductive
so when you do an impression of her
maybe it comes across a little seductive
that's true but um just i'm afraid of
you thought policing my uh intentions
it's just a theory yeah i i don't want
to say whether it's true or not but i
think it might be true well you did have
a crush on her yeah i said that did i
say that to you no but i'm assuming yeah
you're that age you had a you had
crushes on a lot of pretty girls
every every
i think everyone did
melissa milano was you know that we talk
about that in the show yeah a lot of
guests of this show you want to say it
to her because she's heard it julian
heard it and like there's so many guests
of that didn't joe gatto say that she
was yes without think without there's a
lot of people a lot of people she's the
first crush i know and i i also know how
to say that it's a little
i felt um
i didn't want to sound you know just
offensive or productive reductive yeah
in any way
sexist i was i was pretty cautious
talking to her about those things yeah
that i get that yeah so alyssa milano
grew up
on that show 11 tonight i didn't realize
it spanned her those ages
11 and 19. that's crazy and they wrote
it into the show how like yeah hurt her
developing like sam's first bra that was
it episode i can't remember that you do
yes i do i mean remember that
i i because i did watch that show a lot
i mean it was a long time ago my memory
is poor but i do whenever they revolved
around sam i
paid more attention probably
it's interesting though that what that
must have done a lot of development to
be
so exposed i never thought about the
world of course well i mean how could
you have and and especially after
talking to fred savage who had like the
more idyllic version of that i noticed
you kind of poking around trying to um
draw a parallel yeah like that you asked
if she had friends
outside of show business that like kind
of kept her grounded normal like he did
yeah and she didn't yeah you know like
she was friends she was so uh
ingratiated in that world that she would
only hung out with adults yes which i
wonder and it makes sense that she now
has
a certain amount of
jealousy i guess i mean she used that
word so i'm using it
um
towards her own children that normally
they have this normal i know and that
she would go to those lengths to protect
them and she talked about
you know keep having a little chickens
and stuff didn't she talk about that
like her um
you know how she's protecting them and
like
trying to enable them to have like a
more
kind of then also having uncle bradley
cooper and mark ruffalo be such an
active part of their lives true that
doesn't uh i mean what a charmer bradley
cooper oh man you know we don't we've
talked about how of course i mean does
it surprise you at all that he remembers
their anniversary
i knew you know i said all the kids
birthdays
doesn't surprise me a bit bradley is i
mean i've i would say we've met a lot of
charming people in this business i don't
think i've ever i don't think i will
ever meet a more
fully charming
person neil patrick harris is quite
charming of course i've met a lot of
other charming i mean kobe smaller like
there's some charming i've met other
charming people yeah but bradley cooper
is like
charm on steroids you know we got to get
bradley
on the show guess what if he said no he
would say it in the kind of yeah yeah
most wonderful way there was a rumor
that um about us last summer was it that
bradley was
here in our hometown we had moved to
fairfield connecticut yeah that's right
someone started that rumor it's not true
oh well
it turned out yeah he said he said it
was so i reached out to him and i said
um
hey rumors you've moved into and it was
like the hot gossip oh my god everyone
was talking about it pretty it's a small
it's not that small so it's like 60 70
000 people yeah everyone it was like
these stories yeah
the rumor mill was a buzz uh of bradley
cooper's sightings and they saw him here
and he was there with leo and they're
all these uh and so i text him and he
was like no
hey buddy he's like but how are you you
know like so charming and like and uh
and then people continue to see him and
so there was a brief period where i
thought
is bradley lying to me like was did does
he doesn't want you to think he's in
town
[Music]
he's so
insulting and then i thought like well
why would he just
he just wouldn't have written back if he
didn't want to see me right well maybe
not maybe he's so charming he wanted to
make you feel good yeah but he didn't
want to have to see you
that would check out but i don't think
he would do uh no i don't either but um
anyway he is we gotta get him on the
show that would be that'd be great yeah
yeah that would be that would be again
and you know who else does it get alyssa
milano
yes and we got her and man was it what
do you mean we got her i mean we
we got her to be on the show oh yeah
yeah we invited her and she accepted
why'd you get so nervous just now i'm
nervous about words sometimes with some
people
she
like you said she has quite a platform
and she is not afraid to
speak her mind no she's not and you know
it's interesting i thought that when she
was talking about ryan white and and
that whole story i thought god it's
really wonderful what she did and that's
an example of something that should be
apolitical obviously it's like i know
that story
should should inspire
warmth and sympathy
and love in all people regardless of
your political ideology but then
she started talking about um
democrats versus republicans and like
like they're the bad guys and i mean she
didn't use those words exactly but but
that's the idea and i'm not putting it
on her i feel like generally that's
become the problem that you've taken
such sides i know it's not about it's
not really about the issues anymore it's
i know what side are you on yes and if
you're on this side it means that you
think everyone on that side is bad and
evil and if you're on that side you
think everyone on this side is bad so i
think like
the ryan white thing really um sparked
that idea in me that
people should if everyone like
recognized that we all want to get to
the same place but have different
mechanisms
like how we get there
um i feel like we would get so much more
done i know in the politically country i
know but if if it's you if you have a
name if you have a a d or an r next to
your name it it it's it means everything
it trumps any everything any idea it
doesn't mean that there aren't like tons
of like extreme
[ __ ] bad people
on in both parties of course but
i think there i hope i think there are
more people who
want
good things for this country but just
have very different approaches of how we
get there uh that's well said i know i
wish um i don't know what the
prescription is i i do think that i i
really think the continuation of this
uh
vilification of one side or the other
continuation um i think it's i think
it's just fomenting those that sense of
tribalism and that divisiveness it's
it's um
it's such a shame but like
you know and i and i i it was difficult
to talk to her a little bit about that
because
i know that she is very outspoken and
does really take stands on on things and
you know i think in order to do in order
to make change happen you have to do
that i mean you have to
be that outspoken and but i just think
it's different now and it's not her
fault it's like we live in this social
media world where everyone is trying to
find the next like thing to jump on top
of yeah
good and bad but like back in the day
she mentioned people like audrey hepburn
and roberto clemente and paul newman
certainly i know because people were
they were like such forces for good and
i'm not saying that she's not but
there's something more neutral about
how they were seen i think you know paul
newman
look at what he did he like helped kids
right and
republicans and democrats and everything
in between
everyone's gonna agree that that's a
good thing i know he did it it's such an
apolitical right movement you know
whereas
i think some of the issues that alyssa
takes up are
quite politicized and i think that's why
she i think that's why she's very uh
courageous to do that very crazy because
she risks alienating all of these you
know a huge portion of a fan base and
that's ballsy and she doesn't care she
doesn't because she is she's convicted
in what she believes in yeah but like
you said the flip side is
you know continuing to
foment that
divisiveness right um
i don't know i don't know how i i
certainly couldn't do that so i
there's a part of me that it admires
that um because it's it's i don't have
i have convictions but i don't have the
courage to i don't have such strong
convictions that i i would risk i mean
we both get scared about
what words we say i know podcasts i know
at one point she was talking about her
kid writing the governor of florida a
letter uh-huh about oh yes wild cougar
crossing yeah and you just said oh the
animal oh man she was yeah yeah
it really made me laugh well because you
know
what uh it's not the best environment
for
jokes like that
no so i yeah
i admired your uh bravery but
i could be courageous but there was a
part of me that like i realized it was
just i i needed to say it i needed it it
was like
too much to contain i know that loading
is loading from the lid on that pot it
was low-hanging fruit easy let's read a
letter okay
here we go from katie crouch
crowitch crouch
k-r-a-w-c-z-y-k it's a polish i think
wait say it again spell it again rather
um k-a-t-i-e
second name
k-r-a-w c-y
i'm sorry k-r-a-w c-z-y-k
crotchet crotchet yeah i think you're
right karachik it's polish i think yeah
you don't both have to assume that the
name crouching is polish
um subject
amici whoa maybe she's italian wow okay
uh ciao but you know what i in those out
because i as i've discussed spent a lot
of time in some of those eastern
european countries and uh they often
many of them use ciao ciao is like a
pretty in bulgaria they use it uh
estonia anyway
hello justin christian and life is short
crew my name is katie and i'd first put
it on record that contrary to what you
might assume from my subject line i'm
not italian oh
okay and that's the end of the letter
shut up
um however after listening to the
stanley tucci episode i became motivated
to learn how to speak italian i don't
have any that's i would that's a cool
language to i would love to be able to
say because i think it fits the way i
speak anyway i think i speak with you
know um
well you're allowed you know what i'm
going to say uh i don't know how to say
this now i know what you're trying to
say yeah that i speak in a kind of
flowery way well which brings us back to
the beginning that i have some
some of those qualities might be
considered
feminine i think flowery and effeminate
are two pretty different things that's
true because
that's stanley tucci is by no means he
speaks in a italian kind of way yeah but
not like a stereotypical like hey that
this simpsons no i know
or like chico marx right um
okay back to kate however after this
she's gonna learn italian let's go i
don't have any big plans to go there
anytime soon but the fantasy of driving
through the italian countryside eating
amazing food and admiring the culture is
what's keeping me going i totally agree
with her i i want to do that so badly
and both from stanley's show and also
from um i love that movie uh steve
coogan movie with rob um yes uh what's
it called the trip the truth yeah the
italian trip
no no that's the mark wahlberg there's
two or three of them yeah yeah where
they go on a trip in india
those are great i can't believe i can't
think about it no they're so funny one
is just called the trip i think you're
right um
they're great anywho of this funny i was
going to say that and katie says that in
her letter any who
she says in justin's voice well in fact
jerry's yeah you incorrectly attributed
that to me the best best friend of the
show jerry o'connell
lis
uh jerry oc
uh i have a two hour round trip to and
from work so i've decided to split my
time between learning italian via an
italian for beginners podcast on the
drive to work and then i listen to your
podcast on the way home that is such a
good idea i i sorry to keep interrupting
but um
i'm really inspired by this letter so
far because i want to do that and i
spanish is not sticking
i need to find a different
understatement
so far it's been a great balance and
makes the drives less painful about two
hour round trip i wonder where she works
uh i'm such a fan of the podcast and a
huge accepted fan but because of that
movie i have beef with you justin what
do you think her beef is going to be
oh
god i don't know here we go let's find
out i watched it with my older sister
when it was first released and
afterwards i learned the hard way that
[ __ ] is a bad word
not to point fingers but i think we all
know who's to blame for the trouble i
got in with my parents for being a potty
mouth at the ripe age of 10.
wait wait wait wait a minute she didn't
know
at 10 that [ __ ] was a bad word i guess
not
so
you know what's funny i often say i i
was pretty young
um 10 is young but trying to remember i
i was a late bloomer when it came to
that stuff and i
i definitely knew about [ __ ] when i was
third that's third grade cool
do you want a parade i think not
everyone does
i guess so yeah um i was driving in uh
la traffic and i was like oh man and i
pulled up next to um
this car and i was
the the back window was down a little
bit and there was this adorable dog i
was on sunset in highland you know how
it gets really crowded there i was i was
at that light by that in and out and um
there was a really cute dog i was just
staring at the dog i was like kind of
like out of it i've been in traffic and
i was just like tearing the stock and
the
in the driver's side window the
passenger side just went like rolled
down and these two people were like
staring at me and i looked at and i go
oh sorry
sorry i was like checking out your dog
and um
and there was a woman in the front seat
and i think the guy at first i thought
the guy thought i was like checking out
like staring at his
you know
partner
and um the guy goes
yeah i go sorry i was just looking at
that you're talking he goes nah man i'm
a [ __ ]
that's funny yeah and he was like a big
accepted fan anyway um
uh it's back to katie yeah assumes you
feel bad and apologize here oh she
assumed i would feel bad i i don't feel
bad
um because you didn't write it i didn't
write it and um if you're a 10 it is
like a pg-13 movie you know if you if
you didn't know the word [ __ ] by the age
of 10 i would assume that your parents
be watching
yes yeah and the thing with that movie
is i think we've talked about this it
should have been r then there was a cut
that is our where we jonah especially
like had a lot of r-rated ad-libs but in
a pg-13 movie i think you have a
limitless number of shits that you can
say but only one
maybe two [ __ ] and so no apology from
you none okay back to the letter
it's okay all is forgiven and i'll leave
the past in the past she assumes you
would have apologized she's being cheeky
i know since you so kindly apologized
here is a would you rather for you and
christian
wow now i kind of feel bad i didn't
apologize
okay would you rather have the ability
to teleport once a day but never know
the location until you arrive or be able
to teleport wherever you wanted but
every time you arrive to a new place you
turn into a random animal
in each scenario you have to spend at
least 24 hours in the location you
teleport to
okay so
you go to yourself so we're assuming
mammal
it's like animal like a mosquito is not
an animal
well it is it is it's just not that's
true it's part of the animal kingdom oh
yeah yeah i don't i don't think of bugs
as being animals well they are they are
yeah insects um well there's insect
mammal reptile amphibian my answer is my
answer is this yeah
my answer is
i would rather go as an animal
and control where i'm going as long as i
wasn't like a mosquito and someone could
crush me in the 24 hours if i was safe
any non-insect if i was safe and i could
keep a human brain yeah and i can see
that place through yeah for my current
yeah mental situation i would i think
i'd rather be an animal i would too
unless here's the problem if you were if
i popped up as like a jaguar or
something oh and then you'd be you'd be
and then they try to and then i you
couldn't ensure your safety because yeah
because you wouldn't have that animal
brain you'd be like
you'd you everything would be a threat
because you'd have your brain but you'd
be out in the wild in a jaguar people
would all be looking at you and trying
to take you down
because you'd be a threat of course if
you so that's the caveat i would rather
be an animal as long as you could choose
your animal
no not just choose but as long as i was
an animal that didn't draw attention to
itself what animal would be and i remain
safe what animal would best exhibit
those qualities a gnat a gnat yeah well
that's like a mosquito you say you don't
want to be a mosquito i'm not i would be
a mosquito i just don't want to be
crushed oh i see
if i could ensure my safety i would
rather be something small and low
profile i wouldn't i would prefer to be
something if i were to be a bird bird
would be curd i was going to say because
like then you could you could cover more
area and a mosquito just like
they like hover in the same cover more
area every day you get to teleport
somewhere else in the world of your
choosing how much area do you need to
cover on top well let's say you teleport
to
somewhere in like egypt egypt's a huge
country you'd want to make it to the the
pyramids you wouldn't want to spend i
mean like if you're somewhere in like
the desert you know and but you could go
to egypt every day for uh two months if
you want and then you could end up
seeing the whole my point is you have to
spend think about what you say you've
spent 24 hours in the location you
teleport to let's say you teleport to
someone in the gobi desert
why would you do that though
why would you oh
you can pick your place that's true
that's true okay i forgot about that um
also if you're a human if you're
teleporting as yourself into a random
location what if you go like into the
middle of like some war zone right you
know you're in the why would you pick
the war zone it's good because you don't
you don't pick it exactly right exactly
yeah yeah you're right the first one
it's random you're right yeah i would
pick the second one i'd wanna have
control of where i'm going even though
there is something fun about popping up
somewhere it's it's also kind of scary
because what if not just scary but like
potentially kind of boring i think
there's more things in this world that i
don't want to see that i do want to see
wouldn't you agree
a lot i mean you think
i think so
i would say most places in this world i
wouldn't want to spend 24 hours in
oh really oh there's but there's
countless places that i would oh that's
true i mean you know most places are
quite desolate that's what i'm saying
yeah but it's like a beautiful siberia
yeah but you don't you don't need 24
hours in siberia right you need like an
hour to poke around and be like whoa
this is desolate cool you should spend
an hour in siberia yeah
oh no i think you'd find that that's a
good name for a memoir for me an hour in
siberia i think
i don't want to assume but i think
i would guess that if you were in
siberia you you just popped up there
teleported there that you'd want to
spend it would be like really
spectacular this the silence the the
like quality of the air the
the the majesty of the like expanse like
i'd have to figure out a place to sleep
well yeah oh i see what you're saying
i'm just saying the logistics of it make
more sense if you're an animal yeah
that's true you know i just realized i
think i would be i would choose to be
like a pigeon or something because
because um
that's so funny imagining you as a
pitcher well because then i get i'd be i
want to be close to people i want to be
able to get close and pigeons have
access to like the human
human society in a way that most animals
don't you kind of have pigeon energy as
a person yeah like you're always poking
around poking around getting close to
things yeah i'm not i'd like to bop
around it's a good question though it's
great
okay back to katie and now i want to
apologize for her i don't know how what
i could have done to control her having
seen that movie okay back to katie
thanks again for being the best form of
entertainment on my work commutes and
throughout my childhood that is so nice
sincerely katie thank you katie grazie
crotchet grazie for tutti thank you yeah
that was really good uh thanks katie and
we really appreciate that's a really
good letter oh yeah really really good
would you rather good question and if
you guys
would like to write in yourselves
we very much enjoy getting these letters
i think that's evident
i know i just wanted to make it very
clear abundantly clear how much we enjoy
reading these letters and even though we
only read one an episode but we love
reading them and if you'd like to write
in and write your own letter our email
address is life is short wondery.com and
thanks to our guest alyssa milano our
very special guest who has been a very
very um
active present part of our lives since
we were little kids it was that was yeah
pretty surreal it was cool to hear her
voice talk to you grew up watching her
and um it was nice to get to
actually get to know her so i hope you
enjoyed that as well now we need to get
tony downs on the show
yes and uh if you are going to write it
oh man that'd be great to get him on
yeah and danny pintaro yeah the whole
cast
um and if you are going to write in as
christian mentioned uh maybe talk about
your favorite pepper's farm
cookie what pepperidge farm cookie do
you like oh an assignment yes
yes i don't know what a suggestion um
and if you are a representative from
pepperidge farm and you want to
advertise on our show
feel free because uh we're fans okay and
um thank you for for listening to
everyone and uh and hey happy holidays
yeah happy holidays we'll talk to you
next week
life bye be a dream
life could be a dream
there's a time for love and a time for
leaving now's the time we say goodbye
you've been listening to life for sure
no life is short is hosted by me justin
long and it's co-hosted by you christian
long it's also produced by you and
produced by megan v monaco and katie v
allen
senior producers michelle you're like i
see your brain working so hard to do
this that's ours senior producers
michelle miche lance audio engineer is
sergio enriquez executive producer is
marshall louie for a company called
accommodate montreal
bye everyone
[Music]
okay is there funny when like um coaches
no baseball managers come to talk to the
pitcher yes
there's always this this era of like
all right well you gotta go to bed right
now you know like when they like give
the things back like no you did okay
you're like you're just toy back he's
like you're making me
like walk away
yeah
it's so shameful like a new like guy
comes and is like oh yeah i can do
better